let's welcome the red hot chili peppers
to the hollywood walk of fame
[Applause]
now these guys really are some amazing
people and the thing is they really care
i know that they've given hundreds of
thousands of dollars to an orphanage in
peru
they have uh they were the first guys
back before everything was digital you
know in in your era
they uh they were the first guys to do
non-wood post consumer waste paper for
their cds
saving thousands of trees
[Applause]
and uh
you know and not on top of all that they
were the first people to really make the
common ordinary sock a central part of
the fashion wardrobe
hi everybody
[Applause]
when i
was 11 years old
i panhandled on this street
excuse me sir
can you spare some change
can just a dime or a nickel
[Music]
when i was in high school
i marched on this street playing trumpet
in the hollywood high marching band
and i went and played trump at usc too
when i was in my 40s
but
fairfax i had an excess of trumpet
players so i went to fairfax me and
anthony went there hollywood needed one
but
i know this street inside out and this
street knows me
and whenever we've traveled around the
world this street has always been a part
of me
and
i'm really grateful that now we could be
a part of it
i first moved to hollywood in 1987 when
i was 17 years old
and by coincidence my apartment was
exactly one block in that direction
um
i want to thank everybody in the world
who our music means something to
and all the people who came out here
today
and the hollywood chamber of commerce
pumps
[Music]
the hollywood chamber of commerce and
um
and yeah and
and thank you so much to my friends and
this band who've made me what i am
[Music]
and thank you to all you people who came
here you know i i'm so honored and so
it's a really
nice happy occasion today i have to give
a shout out to my brother taylor hawkins
who i love and we will all miss so much
he's flying around i love you taylor he
would he would laugh and make a nice
smart ass comment about this whole thing
and i love him and uh thank you guys so
much for supporting us for all these
years we love you
to me this is not a story of of
individuals
like i love chad i love flea i love john
greatly
um they're amazingly talented flea is
that one with the base john is my
favorite guitar player of all time it is
said that
chad smith is the finest drummer in the
land but really
[Music]
something happens when we come together
which is a much greater than the
individual parts you know the sum total
of our parts is that we were able to
find something that we love doing and
communicate with the entire world
we started off playing dive bars up and
down this street and making a handful of
people dance and come to life
but as time went on you know
we stuck together as a team and as
abandoned now we can make everybody
dance and feel joy and we've been
connected to this this life and this
experience